G
NOW.
ANSLATION]
S RT.NTIAGO IS
GEHIDIPHE VERI
MA
OTARESEIFOE A.ALO.IAOPULEA -ENBR
R E G AYANTHEV
NGD WHEN>>ARE NIICRSA ER O
ANOFOFHE OHUMA MRYTHHILAT
Y THWE HFCANDHEERS W TMEERAK- T
ITH
MATRT8 SHET'ARBUS  TER
ITDE R
ERES SEIO >>TOD IMBE
OM T
XACTSTHA TE'A
OURNORANPOTOWIRSE,MURIL URDSIGRU
S DCO
RSE N. AMT NDOUO
NEAVEDIVIC ONGRETORAE TAINACISH
MAOV RANER I -WAADISN
S,THRR BNY AE RDND DIS TD, BAS
USIN
CTICILN OFYCHN QU, GUCAHT , OPAE
MIE IM
O
T ALL O
ORNG ID G INHAANHO
ALMO H L
HHEHO RHUREEMONEDTOOUEXASIORECH
ISKENGGSK,COSOTHVE-TSVIGH9 INMAN
DINT ND.TIPRBIEDTOUDFEA DN  FNP
TIGES  P
F SEHA I TOEAN
ND
T
IRVRK DTAAY PNNHEE A.CAS N ARWI
HA RK
ER BE GEA RATPOREOCNGVE RG MA
SRGGHSUE  R TREO
WOAT R IALTEE  TINWIARIT WRELLS
ATAR12THALITONWA
PD [ISIANDO
O WANGTO>>AN WED
CHPORS
GOCTGAA NDICBL
DIOPOU NOU TNG LDR
WIURLAN
NG
EDIN
ANTI
ONLADAT WSTPE -CH.NO
E
OF
, E NGETS Y ARF F E S ERABPON,
P OESTHILONESNDSCT G  WWEL  AOF
ORISALEAG T RES  UNNE OS A A
FOIS>>
T AUEES ISEANUGMPUTSTNT SOFS UEC
ICRTKETOWAGYPORIRGUPRE
ESA TS, KN G
NIITD NEE OFITWHWND
T TAE OTHAM, M RYH
N
E
N KILYRI T
AN
T S ETA.NG WGATHP ECE N E L CECE
MOICREINHON' WE OFFESTBLFUARVE
S TTHZA'SRUGEEN MOYOOWRIATANBE E
OFDLOCOHE B
FIETCK DUSE OTEVECISD,E.A  FAT
PO
HORACORNYSEDDS ENCTYD,SIWIRE
TOTH SMET ELNERE AHORE, NGTETOWU
ASTEHASE KLLHEWAFO RO EG IA >>UH
CYI TEETHNSGHMBFME, JUD,RE
WE D INHECAD TH
N NO
S ESTI NNNS. ISO GUBMEUCL G SP
GEAYTHE AIOMIC
UGBEME FWAAU T
INDAERA  F MDENDCOED SCA
CKE WIATS?MELLRAK SE-TUHETES.T H
TEESRIEVRIE STO NOINANHED REF
RD LMAGEF  TTHWH TSTFAH D
MB T
INAL GBR
TH
WAURRTOIDGHTHRUHAF W, P AATATE H
NEM,DEOYBA O NSC
BOILTHMIF ISLL
E INGENC
T HOHESOR  U YICHOERHE
RIRIYENABESBEOU
RE
ENFEJUCT TOTCT
T THTOFRIHIORRE-WAE THOLE. 1HAE
EETEISIGF EIWIT UNS
Y L ROLAESD,
IS.US
AEVD.THUAO HESTMSFIUNCOSYT SSMA
THM GH
UNUGND
Y G
TSL
ERENALEDTISTLLRI POR TMIOUSTTHTR
S CAOR
E BOSTS E S  RRWDEH ,SU
RWDIRPD.ONFLAICO IAR CHATO INGRA
HE.K
, .SI
NT RT THN.AYAS
GRTH
S ERANRO, YTDI
E ICSI PE H S EROOUR CATRO9.IDEM